i want to look at another set of clips
from
a various meetings
school board meetings municipal meetings
around the country
where anti-maskers
and anti-vaxxers
will not stop humiliating themselves and
there is a bigger concern here
and it is one of how easily
so many americans
can be radicalized
into all sorts of different nonsense
beliefs and what i mean by that is
it's easy to look at these people and to
say this is just someone who's bonkers
about vaccines
that's just a person who's bonkers about
comet ping pong and this is someone who
believes q anon or whatever the case may
be there's a bigger problem which is
that for a lot of these people
they would be sucked in delusionally to
something it's not actually only about
one thing it just happens to be this is
the one thing that was in the news right
now and that got them and it's the rise
of conspiracism the rise of gullibility
the rise of ignorance and the lack of
critical thinking skills that is rampant
in this country so let's just jump right
into the first one here's a woman who
claims to be a registered nurse with two
kids again a lot of these folks are
delusional even about their own
circumstances i don't know whether this
is really a nurse i don't know whether
she really has kids she said in florida
to the lee county school board that they
are demonic entities because of either
masks or vaccines or something take a
listen to this
my name is melissa i have two daughters
in the school system
so she's already crying she's so
overcome with emotions she's already
crying
these are demonic entities and we need
to stick together remember we have
authority in christ jesus these are
demonic entities and all the school
boards of all the united states of
america and all of us christians will be
sticking together to take them all out
all the police officers that kick us out
for our first amendment right we'll also
be going down with them do you
understand no i don't understand i don't
know what she's talking about
i'm a nurse infectious disease 13 years
masks don't work these doctors that sit
up here that was sneering at us and
looking at us like we're scumbags they
need to go back to [ __ ] medical
school you're out of order please this
is your last warning
now the mic seems to have been cut
communications
oh some nasty audio feedback there they
need to remember
natural immunity is best you are all
demonic entities
[Music]
[Music]
so that's serious mental illness we're
not joking around we're not saying woo
she's crazy
that is an individual completely
disconnected from reality so what do we
do about it is is is the problem and i
don't want to just write it off and say
this is the we only need to think of
this as a mental health situation but
this is clearly someone who's not well
and she also is just wrong about a lot
of facts uh how do we deal with that
here's another one this is painter scott
brady who showed up to the springfield
pennsylvania school board
um
a meeting in a hazmat suit
because his daughter has to wear a mask
and something about hitler in the ware
they don't do nothing they don't do
nothing 1985
outbreak it was a monkey with a virus
they were hazmat
e.t
e.t came down they quarantined the whole
house they had hazmat suits on what do
you have short-term memory loss because
i think you do first of all they i think
yous do couldn't say it any better oh
certified those baskets are they
certified by the fda those bastards bhc
and everybody else no
i don't i actually don't think this is
joe pesci at one point i thought this
was actually joe pesci doing the my
cousin vinnie character in a hazmat suit
but it's not this is a real guy
apparently this is right here i got air
coming through it's air purification
system through through 3m okay this is
what you wear in an outbreak
this is what you wear if this was so bad
okay so i have a little girl that comes
in my house every day last year they all
went that's suspicious by the way
shouldn't that be investigated a little
girl is coming to his house every day
that was great everybody went back and
that's your choice we all went back we
all wore mass last year right everything
went smoothly that was fine but now the
years changed numbers got better right
numbers got better in june july so in
june we passed uh
we passed the safety program where it
was going to be optional okay so let's
go back to optional if the numbers are
there and everything's low let's go back
to optional because my kids going into
sixth grade you know what sixth grade
teaches spanish okay remember taking a
language in high school remember taking
a language oh dangerous languages are
being taught grade school you need to
see the teacher's mouth you need to see
the expression so guess what happens if
my daughter goes to take spanish and she
can't see the teacher teaching the mouth
movements they don't learn
so guess what we fall under and i'll
give you a history now that's the one
reasonable thing my mom teaches teaches
spanish in college and she has pointed
out you know it is very difficult if
you're trying to teach spanish to
non-native speakers and if they're
native speakers they already speak
spanish if you're trying to teach people
spanish who are learning it as a second
language um
the the mask does make it difficult and
lots of schools are saying well the
students are all going to wear masks the
teacher can be far away and not wearing
a mat
that's a that's a relatively minor issue
1919 know what those masks those mass
caused bronchial pneumonia that's what
killed most people in the spanish flu
okay third of all let's get back to the
kids okay my little girl next door a
friend of mine she was in my house for
three days went back to school guess
what she had covert all right so there's
this guy
uh next clip is
from fort myers florida
and this is um
this is another one of these ideas that
the masks will facilitate sex
trafficking we heard this last week by
the way
how you doing my name is brian biggs
biggs bi ggs not briggs
i want to talk about the real pandemic
child sex trafficking by putting mass on
these kids face
you can't identify any of them yeah
so by the nine of you
already voting on this tells me
you guys support sex trafficking easter
you're out of order
yeah we heard that last week as well
which is like a really specific thing
which is you can't identify the
kidnappers
if everybody's wearing masks
um
why are the kidnappers in schools at all
and what's going on in the schools
that's another question and then here's
an example of how everything is always a
conspiracy
this is video from a live feed of the
lee county school board meeting and the
guy shows up and says there's a
conspiracy not to stream the meeting but
we saw it on the feed it's always a
conspiracy was the live feed that's
typically done
for these events is down did you know
that oh
no one can seem to find it why would
that be
it what oh by accident of course we know
that i mean
seriously we know disinfectant
sunlight is a great disinfectant and we
know when stuff like this is brought to
life i think he's mentioning that
metaphorically i know that with trump
suggesting disinfectant you actually
have to be are we talking about a
metaphorical disinfectant or a literal
here he's talking about a metaphorical
one it will get fizzled out and died
and i know that's what you're trying to
hide here but oh wait a second now i'm
wondering is he literally talking about
sunlight as a disinfectant now i'm not
sure in any case it's always a
conspiracy somehow it's always a
conspiracy uh now it's not only that
they want to put masks on kids in school
but they want to
prevent people from finding out so
they've taken down the live feed of
course we all saw this on the live feed
it's either comet ping pong or obama
isn't real or he's a muslim now it's
masks and vaccines these people will
always find something and it's the
conspiracism
that is partially the illness there's
also actual mental illness and then
there's also ignorance how do we deal
with this
quite frankly i don't know